I haven't told you everything
the city is ground zero in a war it
doesn't even know is happening and
everything changed
this war is bigger than everyone
this is the war I need to fight alone
but the poverty
isn't going to be an easy
what has become here
and if you get in my way
you
hey youtubers its charlie new daredevil
season 2 trailer this is supposed to be
the last big one so let's break it down
I love that there's so much Madame Gao
voiceover in the trailer she's kind of
like the show's version of crane mother
who's a character attached to the steel
serpent one of the mortal enemies of
iron fist
that's the symbol that was on her heroin
that she was selling still seems like
she's a really big presence in Hell's
Kitchen
or in New York in general even if the
hand is going to be the biggest villain
of the season so I'm guessing Madame Gao
is going to be like the main villain for
iron fist and if you guys didn't hear me
talking about it a couple weeks ago they
cast Finn Jones from Game of Thrones as
iron fist they didn't say when that
series is gonna drop so I'm assuming
they'll start shooting later this year
and we'll see iron fist by the fall of
2017 going through the trailer though
let's go daredevil dropping down into
the sewers the last time he was in the
sewers was when he was trying to escape
with one of the Russians any time I
think about ninjas fighting in the
sewers I think about Ninja Turtles
either the hand is using the sewers to
get around or it's using them as a base
of operations I haven't told you
everything stick also going to be a much
bigger presence this year too and I love
that it looks like he's going to be
fighting Elektra it seems like she wants
to stop the hand but she has that line
in the trailer where she's like I'll
kill you if you get in my way talking to
daredevil so she might be fighting for
the Yakuza because even though the hand
originates in Japan just like the Yakuza
there are two completely different
organizations with two different
purposes stakes voiceovers just the set
up for the hand there's a war that's
being waged that nobody knows about
and there's this really awesome quote
about the hand from the comics it reads
the hand has five fingers each of which
can exist independently of others not
unlike the five islands that form Japan
however when the five fingers of the
hand come together for a single unified
purpose the hand becomes an object of
unwavering power and as you see right
here there are five children a giant
hole in the ground so it sounds like
because the hand is tied up in the
occult they're gonna raise five demons
they will form the five fingers that
will then turn into a fist to smash the
earth on the chaste side of things I
don't know if we're gonna see stone
again that's who this person is it seems
like they're putting him forward as the
leader of the chased the TV shows
pulling a lot from the comic
in terms of characters but it's not
doing the exact storyline so we'll see
how much they explained the chaste I'm
guessing quite a bit more because
usually you start with the war teaser
like Matt I need to tell you about this
crazy war that's happening and he
explains the hand then he explains where
he comes from the chaste as he is
explaining things to Matt Punisher
enters the trailer and he's mostly going
after organized crime so that might be
his intersection with Elektra if Elektra
is working for the mob Punisher just
wants to eviscerate all the bad guys no
matter what degree of badness they have
like you have a sliding scale of evil
the hand in Madame Gao being the most
evil the regular mob like the Yakuza
being moderately evil Punisher does not
distinguish so you can see the common
ground for all three of these characters
is going to be the war against the hand
but the conflict with daredevil is all
over just killing people in general just
flat-out murdering people no matter how
bad they are daredevil is a devout
Catholic he is never going to be okay
with that electron the other hand
probably doesn't give a [ __ ] about
killing people but because she probably
works for the mob she also lands on
Punisher [ __ ] list don't know what this
artifact is but I'm guessing that Nobu
is back and this is just some key piece
in raising those demons raising the five
fingers of the hand to inhabit these
bodies ninja rooftop battle gonna be so
badass hard to tell if Punisher is in
prison in that white jumpsuit with blood
all over him or if he's in a
slaughterhouse and that's why he has
blood all over him and I love that
visual metaphor Punisher slaughterhouse
daredevil and Electra having sex in fog
Welles Jim if you look you can actually
see the ropes of the boxing ring she's
kind of like that awful girlfriend that
Matt had in college and they just had
amazing sex but they work terrible
together she just turned him into this
terrible person so they break up he
eventually ends up taking the mantle of
daredevil she comes back into his life
and is this terrible influence on him
but they have amazing sex a little bit
of Karen paid shipping it seems like she
actually finds out who the Punisher is
so I'm pretty sure that she's gonna find
out that Matt is daredevil even if they
don't openly acknowledge it she'll at
least figure it out on her own the
battle has begun so it just sounds like
there's gonna be blood in the streets
which I like the metaphor because it's
daredevil so the world is on fire he
sees red all the time fight scenes look
totally on point be sure to look out for
specific comic book
they tried to mimic with their fight
scenes and let me know in the comments
what are you most hype about for
daredevil season 2 I really just cannot
wait to see The Punisher wreck everyone
he's gonna be so much fun but just
explain if you guys haven't seen my
other daredevil videos when everything
drops Thursday at midnight I'll probably
do a video for like the first three
episodes that'll just post like right
after I get done watching those then
after I pass out from exhaustion for a
little while I'll try to post a new
daredevil video just like it through all
the episodes so they'll probably be like
four or five daredevil episode videos
I'll try to get everything out within
the first week ten days tops it's gonna
overlap a little bit with Batman V
Superman the next week because that's
dropping in the middle of the week so be
sure to subscribe to get everything if
there's any bonus videos that you guys
want me to do it's mostly gonna be
episode videos till I get through all
the episodes then I'll talk about
daredevil season 3 what I'm hoping is is
that we'll get like five seasons of
daredevil they've renewed series that
are just absolutely terrible
so if daredevil is an awesome TV series
that everybody loves of course they're
gonna keep it going but remember Luke
Cage is also dropping September 30th
this year so sweet christmas is coming
twice this year I am expecting some
cameos from the other Netflix characters
during daredevil season 2 but only minor
like the way we saw the daredevil cameo
during Jessica Jones and if you haven't
watched that yet I recommend you catch
up on daredevil season 1 and Jessica
Jones the beauty of Netflix is that it's
all there it's already been posted so
it's not like you have to wait week to
week to get episodes new agents of
shield tonight I'll post that video
after the episode airs there's also some
more spider-man that I'm gonna do and
there's a new flash video so that all
I'll post in the next day or so and if
you're wondering about my Gotham video I
still get lots of questions that posted
on my facebook page that's facebook.com
slash emergency awesome if you guys do
want some daredevil reading recommends
for season 2 you can click here for my
last daredevil video I explained to some
specific comics for the Punisher and
Elektra to read and you can click here
for my Black Panther Civil War video
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you